he is part of the eight and a half hour
extravaganza
that i'm uh proud to host for nfl
network on sunday nfl game day morning 9
a.m eastern time all the way to 5 30 in
the afternoon for super bowl 55
the double nickel himself from those
first dynastic patriots teams
willie mcginnis part of that broadcast
and back here on the show how are you
willie
i'm doing well rich how are you i'm
doing fine it's like groundhog day here
we are let's talk brady right the super
bowl how they're gonna stop brady
it's crazy it's i mean we've got
honestly it's i i i could just pull out
my notes from like 2000
when you were playing against him and
it's the same thing get him off the spot
can you can you confuse him uh it's
crazy
really nuts it's pretty surreal rich
um i was just talking to a couple of
guys and i did notice something
these two offenses are the most
talented offenses in each conference
if you look at the kansas city chiefs
and all the weapons they have
offensively
and if you look at if you look at the
bucks all the
talent that they have i don't think you
can find another team on each side
that has this much talent playing in a
super bowl that's going to go head to
head
it's pretty explosive like there's a
there's a thousand storyline
that you can just go up and down and
talk about and match up some different
things
and it makes it for it makes it for a
great game
so um let's just before we get into
some deeper x's and o's let's just again
get inside brady's mind best you can
tell
is there any part of him quiet moment
where he's apparently got
tons of them because he mentioned gisele
took the kids out of the house
so he's home alone like kevin you know
back in the movies
uh to watch film and just being able to
to focus on everything
do you think he sits there and thinks to
himself at any point in time
you know um that mahomes is on pace
mahomes
is getting off to a very nice start here
that it is possible
with everything set up that his records
that he's setting right now could
way down the road be threatened and
that's part of the motivation for him
on sunday as if he needs any more is
that do you think at all possible
willie i think as a competitor
um rich the answer is yes in a sense
i think as a competitor you always
want um to use whatever it is
to motivate you whether people are
saying you're the
you're the old head is what they're
calling them the old head and the young
kid on the block is coming to take over
um if somebody's saying he's on pace to
break
every record and everything you've done
uh whatever
whatever the noise is out there i think
as a competitor
that's had so much success over the
years
so much success uh in order not to
become complacent in order
to always compete at a high level and
and have an edge and find something
to be upset and motivated and mad about
going into a game you can use whatever
it is
and i think for brady he understands
where he
is he doesn't care about where he's been
and what he's accomplished he just knows
this is the next one
it's big it's legendary
it's historic and it's something
in a lot of ways that's never ever
happened
um in nfl history that he's doing
the journey and the role he's on and i
would say
for you know mahomes yes he's on track
to do a lot of great things but there
are so many things that have to be in
place
with coaches with players with talent
with mentality
with systems whatever it is that you got
to keep in place to have this type of
longevity
and long-term success that it just gets
in the way and makes it so tough
so in my opinion what tom brady has
achieved over his career
or never ever be duplicated
by another player again there's just too
many things that have to factor in
um i have to stay in place for it to
happen
and i think he's
talking to himself saying
i want more and more and more the more
they say i can't do
the more i'm gonna do i'm at six
nobody's had six but jordan
and a whole nother sport i want seven
after seven i'm ready to go after a
couple of weeks
and start working on number eight that's
just his mentality
he's not gonna get complacent he's not
gonna get relaxed
until like he says until i suck and then
i'll sit back and reflect on
everything i've done and all the
accomplishments and all the other stuff
but right now
like history is continuously in the
making
and he understands that that's why i've
said his legacy is already way secured
because his legacy is too much is never
enough that's his legacy
you know right period and end of story
um william mcguinness here on the rich
eisen show so
look you know better than anybody else
that that crazy things happen
in a super bowl and you never know what
can turn a game but
that said the match up that you think uh
super bowl 55
hinges on uh x's and o's
is what willie mcginnis
i think it's going to come down to the
defenses um
i think we both understand clearly how
how explosive both offenses is
so it's going to be the defense that
when
either team gets in the red zone at
least 50 percent of the time or half the
time
can you limit them to field goals
instead of touchdowns
um the pass rush is going to be crucial
for both sides
the bucks i think have a better pass
rush overall
uh because they got interior and guys on
the outside that can win the one-on-one
battle across the board
the chiefs they have chris jones and
they have clark
they got guys that can get there as well
um
you know and i think if you can't
control the trenches and dictate
that and contain the quarterback whether
it's brady
you know uh getting to the pocket and in
pot
impacting the pocket with mahomes
keeping him in the pocket
and putting pressure on him with four to
five only
um so you can drop everybody else and be
physical with the receivers at the line
you don't have a chance you don't have a
chance in this game we've already seen
playing against the chiefs whether it's
zone whether it's man
whatever it is they got an answer for it
so you've got to come up with multiple
ways to be effective and it starts up
front
you can't get pressure win a one-on-one
battles which they just lost their left
tackle
um the centers on covet alert right now
and they've had to shuffle move guys
around that's going to be crucial in
this game
which front seven and front four can
affect the pocket
the most well the one
match up i came on the air to mention
and i'm not mentioning this to you so
you can echo back
uh whether i'm right or not uh the
reason why i bring it up is you are
you know clearly one of the best
linebackers i've ever seen play
and i just think the way that levante
david and devon white have been playing
have been off
the charts and here comes kelsey their
way to me this is the match-up
for super bowl 55 how do you see that
one playing out
it is it is the match-up because i think
todd bowles has
you know he's had he has done it rich he
has
mixed coverages he has mixed the pass
rush he's brought
devon white and levonte david but these
are two of the guys
that are the best probably at playing in
space and coverage
in the league as a tandem they're
probably the best
and when you look at kelsey he's the guy
that is the crucial part of their
offense
because he plays every single receiver
position
the x the y the z the h he plays the f
in motion he plays in the slot he plays
everywhere
so you have to have a guy physical
enough to line up
you got to have a guy athletic and fast
enough to run with him
and to be able to contend when the ball
is in the air
so whether you're mixing a linebacker
like devin white who we saw in coverage
can pick the ball off play great in
space or lebron say david
or you're putting a safety you know and
and one of your linebackers underneath
it just depends
but he is the guy that is going to break
everything open
and you have to stop no matter what it's
kelsey so you got to figure out how to
mix and match that
and change things around but one way is
not going to win the game for you
defensively
because they have so many adjustments
and personnel groups and formations that
they use
um it's tough you know and stuff andy
reed and the enemy they do a great job
and make it hard for any defense ask the
poll question of willie mcginnis before
we send him on to his day
chris he's got a lot of he's got a lot
on his plate today go for it
all right willie sadly it's the
anniversary of the helmet catch
sorry bud what's the worst way to lose
the super bowl
the helmet catch the butler pick kevin
dyson tackled at the one or scott
norwood missing a field goal
wow well i wasn't there for the helmet
catch
um i was in cleveland so um
that one didn't hurt me too bad i wanted
to see my guys win but i wasn't on that
squad
i would say the dyson man you know
coming up
coming up like an inch or a half a yard
short
of the of of reaching the ball and
they're giving that last effort or
whatever getting in there bill those are
tough
but i would say that just being so close
but so far
huh well i mean the uh the question for
the regular season
what's the worst way to lose a regular
season game was having one of the best
defensive players
uh go off due to cramping but come back
right away and tackle edger and james in
a game that was the winner of that
question
[Laughter]
oh wow now it's crap and i didn't know
it was crap and i thought i jammed my
knee in the church or something and now
it's trapped
is that what it was changes every time
it gets better and better every time but
i mean you
you came back like running like a deer
or willy i mean
that's a hall of famer you stopped
sprinted to midfield
[Laughter]
we're gonna have a fun eight and a half
hours will we we're gonna have a fun
eight and a half hours
on sunday hanging out we will look
forward to it i look forward to it too
will it you take care of yourself thanks
for the call i always cherish it thank
you
anybody truly thanks guys we'll let me
get us out willie mcginnis on both
twitter and instagram
here on the rich eisen show